hey everybody it's time for another
movie retrospective yeah
Briony animator yeah we're doing this
one because well because we did
reanimate her a long time ago and we
also did society which was yeah the
movie that brian has not directed before
this one I was shocked I he also did
beyond reanimate her today yeah I was
shocked because I had never seen this
one yeah you thought you would seen it
but then I started watching it yeah
seeing it I thought I'd seen all the
reanimated movies yeah and I was
watching this one man remember this is I
had never seen the movie well now yeah
I'd heard of it that's hot and I didn't
well yeah like it voted it is actually
this one came out in 1990 Stuart Gordon
did not direct it I believe he wanted to
and he like had a whole bunch of ideas
about you know what the next story was
gonna be and stuff like that but
apparently the timeline for it was like
not long enough for his liking he wanted
like six months to kind of like work on
the script and stuff and they were like
ya know that's like way too long
so they gave it to his longtime partner
Brian Jasna who as I said had been like
producing the reanimate her movies and
he's directed the very weird body or a
movie Society only a couple years prior
to that one I like though yeah we
reviewed that one I think I like this
one better but not too long ago I think
I do as well
this one okay so the thing is yes it's a
sequel and it's actually a continuation
of HP Lovecraft's novella uh you know
Herbert West ring animator this is kind
of like focuses on I think like the
fifth and sixth chapters of the novella
that's why at the beginning of the movie
you know dr. West and his little partner
in crime are in Peru like gathering body
parts like from soldiers and stuff like
that because that's why I don't remember
if it was Peru in the book but that's
what they were doing at that point in
the in the story was they were doing
that so even though it doesn't really
have anything to do with the rest of the
movie they I guess they just what kind
of wanted to put it in no explanation of
how they got there who they were
fighting for what the war was about but
they were just working on some soldiers
there are some peruvian soldiers there
yeah and just like was just the excuse
to show you a cool scene right before
the the the credits yeah it was just
like a good like Tyler ban you don't
mean that like I said they could say was
like paying homage to the original story
even though it doesn't really have
anything to do with this plot yeah so
this one takes place eight months after
the events of the first movie now the
funny thing about this is that um okay
so continuity not really an issue
because a lot of time in it it's like
funny because Brian guys know like I
sound like a little bit of a nerve you
with him about that and he's like it as
it turns out who cares the tone of this
movie is very much like Evil Dead yes
ash vs. Evil Dead it's it's it's a silly
horror movie with a lot of facili crazy
ideas it was the kind of [ __ ] that would
trip us out when we were we were kids
and back in 1990 oh yeah definitely they
were showing you stuff you had never
seen before really and they didn't care
if they didn't really have the budget to
make it look realistic and it didn't
matter it was it had a very colorful
color they had a really colorful palette
the color palette was almost kinda like
a jolly movie and it was almost shot
kind of like almost kind of like a comic
book movie of the era almost kind of
like Creepshow yeah they definitely this
one it's like I don't want to say I mean
it still has a comedic tone to it I
don't know if it's I'd say it's quite a
zany as the first one because this one
definitely has omage is to the universal
monster movies of the 30s and 40s so
it's a lot has a lot more of like a
gothic thing going on it and I don't
think the humor is is quite over the top
but it might be gory or than the first
one yeah I think it probably might yeah
more stuff happens in it I mean it was
trying to top the first one yeah and I
can't leave I didn't see it I can't
believe it oh yes I had just joined the
army what what when in 1990 did this
actually come on did he give you a month
no alright I must have been real close
to join the army didn't hear about it
listen I would we would have rented this
instantly well yeah but I'd heard about
it later on and I just assumed that hats
that I'd seen it yeah cuz you know how
it is you know sometimes all confused to
movies together at all just kind of you
know there's no reason to really
remember these movies line by line that
not for me I just watched him as a kid
you know well yeah I mean unless you saw
them like a whole bunch of time right or
unless they made like a huge gigantic
impression Lee yeah time I was watching
it and I was like I don't remember this
oh man I don't really remember that then
I'd see something brand new no I've
never seen this well it's weird because
it's like I saw this one back in the day
like maybe in the early 90s I don't
think I saw it in the theater but um I
didn't remember it I must have only seen
it once because I didn't remember it as
well as the first free innovator cuz
that one I saw like a whole bunch of
time it's like on cable and stuff um but
this one like I said there's no
continuity or anything like that because
if you'll remember at the end of the
first movie um dr. hill the guy who was
the animated head yeah um his head
pretty much got smushed at the end of
the first one right because didn't that
other zombie like squish his head and
like throw it against a wall and then to
jelly or something that a long time but
in this one his head is just as fresh as
Daisy and it's still like it comes back
like haunting dr. West even though the
funny thing about it is that he doesn't
really um he's not like really the main
antagonist I don't guess he's just kind
of like in the movie it's a you know
it's almost I don't want to use the word
shoehorned in but the reason that he's
in there is because the actor David gale
called up Brian yes but Brian has de and
said hey you making another reanimate or
maybe in that [ __ ] so it's like he's
like alright so he just wrote him in
there even though his head got mushed in
the last one yeah there was no reason
for him to be in there really but in the
context of the late 80s and early 90s no
that was that was fair yes yeah game
because the fans of the first movie just
wanted to see the dude again that he
didn't care if it didn't make sense yes
that's what I mean so it's like and I
and Brian Gaza didn't care it's like he
just called me up in there you know they
didn't think like oh no what are we
gonna do is head got smushed in the last
one it's like but they were just like
whatever it's not what these movies were
for get high or something at home with
the VHS you and your buddies and talking
about you know some girl you went to
high school with you know you you you
you're gonna have a date with her next
week something like that that was what
it was like during those days yeah you
know but the funny thing about this okay
so like I said this picks up eight
months later and dr. West and his little
buddy there are working in Peru and then
they get attacked or some [ __ ] like you
know there's some nice gore at the
beginning they get attacked or whatever
and then they subsequently go back to
the hospital like the Miskatonic
University Hospital and both get jobs
there even though they were the only
survivors of the so-called Miskatonic
massacres that happened at the lassen
you think that they'd be suspect you
think they'd be suspects or something
but again it's like it really just don't
worry about it so they just came back
and they're totally working like totally
normal doctors like you do and this is
normal for the genre I mean that ash vs.
Evil Dead and the Evil Dead series and
everything know that [ __ ] you do to go
to jail yeah you were here I'm gonna beg
you to go to jail for many times over if
you were you know run around the
chainsaw on your arm and killing zombies
and how are you gonna prove that that
was a zombie yeah and and not you know
it was dead before I killed it doesn't
work in the real world yeah well I think
the same situation here it's like I
don't even think they have a throwaway
line about it's like oh we were
exonerated of all charges or whatever
because you know clearly some what they
do in this one is they take it up to the
next level because in the first one the
beheaded doctor was still walking around
they thought about that so what can we
do at that concept so later on now you
got Herbert West making monsters yeah
putting a head on top of the leg and
bringing that's alive alive taking a
bunch of fingers and eyeballs and just
putting those together real quick and
turning those love to make a little
spider
you know just [ __ ] like that yeah that
weren't really explored in the first
movie there is explored in this one
because I think in the first one I mean
in the first one dr. West was more and
again shadow like shout out to Jeffrey
Combs I loved Jeffrey Combs Jeffrey
Combs if you're listening I love you
it's like he is just I love that he just
took this character and he just made it
instantly iconic because he takes it
really seriously like he gives
like these really great like monologues
and stuff like that and he's just this
[ __ ] great like over the t-connector
yeah one of my you know not only is he
great at Herbert West but he was man he
was great and starting what was it in
Star Trek where the stress ran right
yeah Star Trek Enterprise he played
general Shran yeah and that was he's one
of the best Star Trek characters you
know the you know of all times
he ain't convinced me he was a military
officer he's like a blue General Patton
had me convinced getting castle freak to
and he actually plays kind of a normal
person in that he was like deep space
not a lot you know you played he played
aliens yeah you know cuz he I mean he's
kind of a weird guy yeah he can do
anything and then and he not like
Crispin Glover weird but on that
spectrum even did a great job and I'm
one of my favorite horror movies was
frighteners yeah and he played that up
yet creepy s FBI agent that was cool too
he just does really like I said he he
kind of has like a little bit of a
Crispin Glover vibe like not quite as
weird as Chris Crispin Glover but he has
cuz he can act normally at Christmas
ever I don't think an act normally that
good dude is but um yeah cuz I think
he's just like that naturally he could
act [ __ ] [ __ ] and creepy we wants
to yeah and he's really really good at
it but he's also like really compelling
to watch yeah you believe it yeah so I
feel like in the first movie he was more
concerned with like just reanimating the
dead like with his reagent
whereas in this one maybe the reason
they were in Peru was because didn't
they go into that thing where like he
found he had an iguana and they said
they they took some some like the
amniotic fluid like out of the lizards
thing it like yeah you know what I mean
and so one day he made reagents out of
that somehow he's making reagent up so
I'm guessing this like an improved
reagent because this can bring back just
like one body part and there's a whole
thing about how like each body part has
like its own consciousness kind of yeah
like the thing almost yeah so it's like
essentially like that so in this one it
feels like yes they're building up to
just like in Bride of Frankenstein which
is obviously a no Maj - but he's
building up to you know building an
entire woman out of spare parts but
along the way he also
seems to just make all these other
little creatures just for the hell of it
just because he wants to cuz yeah you
know they don't they don't don't
Chronicle all that they just showed him
make a couple of them but towards the
end you realize they show you he made a
bunch of yeah yeah like make it up like
the weirdest should they could think of
and of course you know they play it up
and makes his version of the bride you
know of course she's hot he's got the
legs of a hooker and oh this is a ballet
dancer ballet dance he's been stealing
body he said just finding a hot girl
like reanimating her he's got to take
pieces and put them together like yeah a
challenge yeah you know and of course
she lets off cooking like but like
something out of some kind of bondage
fantasy she's partially skinned and you
can see ribs but it's kind of artistic
almost kind of like a santa bite and in
and she was in like a like a bridal
outfit was she sort of it was like a
shroud as yang just like inbred yes
Ghazi kind they had her all kicked out
and everything you know that was toward
towards the end and of course that
doesn't go down the way it's supposed to
you know kind of like kind of like kind
of like Bride of Frankenstein yeah
that's definitely what this is a
marching like I said not only the HP
Lovecraft story but um you know the
chapter four and five specifically in
the West for animator well I think
Herbert West might have been inspired by
dr. Frankenstein yeah oh yeah that
Lovecraft you know he wrote he read all
the classics yeah I think that I think
basically he's a he's a knockoff well I
think only so pretty much any mad
scientist's right it's kind of like an
homage to I mean cuz Frank dr.
Frankenstein I don't assume lady what
was I have to see what Lovecraft
originally wrote i I've never read
anything about I heard that was he he
just mentioned him a little bit yeah
in and out of the stores I've you know I
mean I don't hadn't read would what
Lovecraft wrote about Herbert West yeah
it's a whole novella I read it but it
was a long time ago I have it over there
I have like a book with all his fiction
in it that friend of mine this is like
way back in the day he I think he told
me he thought that he was just mentioned
a few times yeah and HP Lovecraft
stories but you would know more than me
yeah well like I said it's been a long
time since I've read this particular
novel because it's funny because this
would all be you could copy you could
you could copy all this it's it's in
public domain so by yeah why hasn't
somebody come out with an HP Lovecraft
reanimate or you know Herbert West
reanimate or movie just like the book
for the novella I think it'd be a budget
you don't know I feel like that would
probably happen because I mean look at
all the like Stephen King adaptations
they've been making like you know all of
the Stephen King adaptations pretty much
like the last couple years so early next
year they're doing an adaptation of the
Lovecraft story the color out of space
so if that does well maybe that will
kick-start like a whole yeah and there's
been like some kind of popular like last
couple years some kind of popular
Lovecraftian movies like not based
specifically on Lovecraft stories but in
that mythos kind of thing like the void
and stuff like that so I feel like maybe
there maybe it's Lovecraft's moment you
know what I mean but we'll see how the
color how he was running out of
properties they're burning them all up
so bad they're gonna have to come up do
something and interestingly too in
January they're making another
adaptation of Henry James the turn of
the screw so maybe they're kind of going
back to like a lot of classic horror
which I don't have a problem with that
really cuz there's like a lot of really
good [ __ ] like in the public domain that
would make really good movies and yeah
you don't gotta paint nobody for the
rights yeah you don't gotta pay a script
well you still gotta pay a screenwriter
cuz they still have to yea adapt it and
[ __ ] like that like for modern audiences
but yeah so the the whole thing comes
about like the whole creation of the
bride of re-animator comes about because
from the first movie you know Barbara
Crampton character she did not return
for this one because her agent
apparently she after reanimate her
happened cuz I loved Barbara Crampton -
she's totally rad but um after her
reanimate her she her career actually
kind of started to take off she was on
like a big soap opera maybe was Days of
Our Lives I can't really remember but
her agent told her not to do the bride
of re-animator sequel she said oh you
know you're too big for that now and you
know you know you did you know it's just
like you're too classy for that shoot so
she was like well okay and she didn't do
it little of those pranksters know that
that these movies like this stay around
forever that's what I mean these horror
movies are eternal and we talked about
this before it's over-the-top it will
never be forgotten
yeah it's like everyone will remember
you and it's like you know 30 years from
now your watch you'll be like an old
lady with a walker at a horror
convention convention and everybody will
come up and want your autograph these
movies are old and I want to buy them
all on blu-ray yeah but it's hard to get
them on blu-ray because it may be the
licensing conflicts or something
sometimes you can't get a ball together
yeah and like you get the movie and
there's four different like slightly
different versions of it on blu-ray yeah
what um I believe very recently arrow
uh just did like a three disc blu-ray of
this it looks really nice and it's been
like all restored they have like the
Unrated version they have the theatrical
version and of all these [ __ ] extras
and stuff on there really really nice
packaging and stuff I think we animators
expensive yeah I mean you expect to pay
like 60 bucks well they're booked you
know you want the steelbook you know
just kind of deal or you know kind of
like yeah if you're gonna if you're
gonna get it get the nice I really do
like this steelbook so yeah like really
nice we have a bunch of those yeah if
I'm gonna get him I watched you books
yeah I mean you don't they like a lot of
- they're more you know yeah they're
more well there's more extras in them
that's you and they're just better to
look at and the artwork is really nice
later paper done a really good look from
a generation we like to have a physical
product you buy it you actually have it
yeah on your hand nobody can take it
from you well you lose your internet
connection that you can still watch it
then you can watch it yeah so the whole
the whole creation of the bride
initially comes about well I mean it
looks act like dr. West wants to do it
anyway but he tries to get um you know
his buddy on board by saying that he
still has Megan's heart that he stole
from like you know that was the only
piece of her left from yeah you know
from that was Barbara Barbara Branson's
character that was the only piece of her
left from the Miskatonic massacres so
you know as weak willed that's this
[ __ ] foot yeah he's always kind of
like horrified but then he's like just
kind of want to go along with it there's
like the two guys it's like there's a
weird there's like a weird relationship
between the two of them exactly
was in the first one as well because it
seemed like he was almost like dr. West
was almost like jealous of his
relationship with Megan and it's kind of
like that in this one too because in
this one even though you know even
though he's still like pining over Megan
who died he's still he's gone after like
this new woman he's kind of sort of
dating this new woman so there's kind of
like this really weird like I said
there's really no through line of likes
you know there's a plot and there's like
a narrative thing but it's like
sometimes characters like do one thing
in one scene and then they do that thing
in the next scene and it's like just
don't [ __ ] worry about it probably
man edited out I think they went I think
certain things might have been edited
and and like I said before I think
there's like three or four different
versions of each one of these movies
depending on where yeah what the market
was kind of rating they had to go for I
think that had a lot to do with some of
the confusion that is there what you see
but doesn't matter the time of the movie
allows for it you're not watching it for
the reasons of like you know continuity
and to make sense you know this is not I
mean it makes sense
yeah but certain details you know the
main kind of really don't Java it
doesn't matter
yeah it doesn't like I said it's it's
just kind of the thing where you have um
Dan you know the friend and he's kind of
like still sad about Megan dying cuz
like I said it's only about eight months
so it has been that long
so he's still sad about that he's like
he'll never find anyone to replace her
blah blah blah but then he's also kind
of like dating this new woman and he's
also kind of in love with this patient
of like this terminal patient yeah
that's dying like one of his patients in
the hospital so he just he's got all
kind of [ __ ] going on and he like
doesn't know what to do ends up mixing
all these women together into one body
and then put the barber grandma's heart
because yeah cuz Herbert West had this
theory that each cell had its own life
and so her life force would still be in
it he's [ __ ] and he's just yeah he
was just trying to get there and I'm
just trying to make a damn that's just
trying to make a damn Frankenstein he's
like this is the only part of her that
will still live yeah towards the end you
got the Bride of Frankenstein running
around right yeah but she you know the
brighter
animator but it's a Bride of
Frankenstein type creature and then you
got the old dude showing up headless guy
showing up and he's implanted bat wings
on the side of his head
yeah he got that other that other weird
doctor yes another doctor that's
reanimate did that reanimate the
preimage dr. Hills head by because you
know he's like hey free head and he took
it in tick as an office and he's like
hey free glowy stuff anything and he
injected it and I seen reviews about
movies like this from younger guys there
and and in the reviewers like what the
[ __ ] happened in this movie where people
think people were not thinking the way
you think now they were just fun yeah
was this a fun movie let's supposed to
be reality and it's a showcase for the
gore yeah and like just to see how over
the top they go you could tell like I
said particularly in the little subplot
if you want to call it that of dr. West
like just for shits and giggles like
making all these monstrosity yeah like
it's like hey I'm gonna sew an arm to a
leg
yeah like bring it to life and
imperfection and it kicks them and stuff
imperfections and the executions of the
movies and the effects that didn't
bother us at all that added to the charm
we liked it that's what I mean it like
we knew that stop-motion yeah you know
although that is really good stop-motion
good fingers and the eye is really it's
up and then like there was even in
certain classic you know movies like
Evil Dead if you pay attention you can
see the top of the set it's yeah it's in
the shot yeah that though you can see
the wall the wall does not meet a damn
ceiling you know me but people still
forgave it didn't matter
well what a movie is entertaining and
fun you can tell that the people made it
were like super into it and they were
having they're just trying to entertain
you and they're just try it yeah it's
like so yeah it's cut you know what it
means so it's kind of like well like you
said it just kind of like adds to the
charm of it yeah but I have to say that
you know all is so all of those
creatures are like super fun because you
could tell that the whole [ __ ] you
know effects crew it was like screaming
mad George who also did society and like
a bunch of other effects crews maybe I
think maybe candy it works on it too
yeah I'm pretty sure they did and you
could tell they were just trying to
listen to like hey let's make a thing
that's like Park
and like with a snake buzz let's make
this than the other and there's you know
what I mean it'll take dr. what dr. hill
but we'll put batwings on who's gonna
fly these movies were basically jokes
and you were in on the joke and they
knew you were in on the joke you you
would your is a team effort yeah there's
a team effort
and like you know that one thing that
kind of because I hadn't seen this in a
long time and one thing that kind of
startled me about it is like wow really
bad things happen to some animals and
it's like not really but I mean really
bad things happen to some animals in
this movie not only does that poor big
fruit bat get its wings get off yeah
with a scalpel and then later the real
animals know they're not realizing this
isn't like Cannibal Holocaust okay but
um you know and then the wings get sewed
on a dr. hill severed head but also um
that one character that Dan Kane is
dating that journalist or whatever the
hell she is her dog gets killed by one
of the zombies and it like pulls his
pulse its leg off or some [ __ ] yeah I
got a dick threw it up against the wall
and that [ __ ] it up pretty bad and
then of course Herbert West was like Oh
can't waste this dog so he takes the dog
and like puts like a human arm work on
the head like it brings it back to life
and [ __ ] it doesn't make any sense it is
it like I said just like just sit back
and let it roll over you it's like like
I said I don't think it's as narrative
ly cohesive as the first one it's not as
simple as the first one the plot in this
one is a little overstuffed there's like
kind of a lot of stuff that's going on
that doesn't really need to be in like
dr. hill doesn't need to be in there
like with the head and everything is an
excuse I know you some kind of a [ __ ]
right that's why it's just kind of like
they were like whatever we're just gonna
like put it all in there and in the
thinking of the time part two is gonna
have to part if it's gonna have to top
part one yeah and it did looking better
generally the last um you know the third
act which is look really really good
like one when you see kind of like all
the weird creations that dr. West's made
like in this tomb behind the behind
their lab but also the design of the
bride is [ __ ] great it's so good it's
like one thing that I liked about you
know when they're showing them like over
the course the film like constructing
her one thing that I like and I saw
another reviewer mentioned this as well
it's like that it looks like that body
could actually work like the way they
made it like you know what I mean he
made like a little cooling system or
whatever and they're like he put all
these tubes in there too likes to make
all the blood go through like so he's
making everything yeah and he has like
all these like little metal joints like
sticking things together so it looks
like it could actually kind of function
I don't know if it could but now there's
like movies after this one right was it
just one more there was one more and
then there were some other like because
we did we did like beyond reanima yeah
we argued that as well yeah that's the
prison one that was the prison one and
that one I think even tops this one so
they progressively they just wanted to
get a Gurion go and they did get better
I think they got better I still like the
first one the best but they each have
their charms yeah you know what I mean
but I have to say that like the the
construction like when the bride wakes
up and like the last scene of her you
know cuz at first Dan seems like he's
kind of into it but then he has like the
live girlfriend and she's like what the
[ __ ] is this all like she would stay
with him after she saw that but whatever
so it's like so she's like what the [ __ ]
is this and then there's like this weird
jealousy thing in the living woman and
the bride yeah and it's like you know
what I mean and then dr. West is like
saying the bride was like superior
because they made her and all this other
kind of stuff and so and he gives his
like play you know he's better than God
kind of speech which is really super
awesome yeah and it's like and then but
then Dan seems to like have a change of
heart and like I said it's one of those
things where it's like one scene he's
like oh yeah and then he's like oh yeah
cuz I've never mind he calls her a
monster yeah and then she gets like
really upset about it and you know she's
like what do you want from me what do
you want and it's like all he/she says
Lachey kundur stands at all he wanted
was the heart because that was Megan
yeah so she reaches in the chest and
just pulled the [ __ ] thing out and
then the best thing and I'm it's like
there's behind-the-scenes footage and
I've seen part of it but it's like it's
hard to tell how they actually pulled
this off because it looks amazing but
she apparently has tissue rejection as
dr. West calls it yeah and she basically
just starts falling apart yeah yeah
that's cool and it looked great I mean
it looks [ __ ] ripped like her head
goes up like ten stars and then her arms
start falling off and
like evers like she just starts falling
apart at the seams it's just like a [ __ ]
yeah it's worse late effect and of
course that really doesn't make sense
because the zombies that he created in
the first movie are still running around
and they weren't rejecting must have
been the new serum or something that he
was making yeah because they were
different seriously and they were also
different body parts yeah different
people and different animals and man put
together so yeah most of them what he
was talking yeah because I think that
was the big difference in the first one
he was just reanimating like a dead
person that was all one piece and this
one he was specifically trying to
animate pieces separately and then put
them all together and you know animate
those good well it's a good one like I
said I don't like it as much as the
first one and I think it it doesn't get
is it gets kind of more mixed reviews in
the first one cuz I mean everybody loves
the first one this one has little more
mixed reviews but because it's a little
bit different the first one actually
like you said was a simple movie and it
yeah I had and it's kind of a weird
element of plausibility to it yeah this
one they were said now [ __ ] the
plausibility let's just yeah top it and
make it even crazier yeah this is the
third one's even crazier than that yeah
but I like I liked him all I did to you
I like them all I mean this one yeah
like I said they're not super worried
about continuity the first one they're
not super where I mean it's kind of
continuous with the first one but not
really this like some characters that
are dead to come back and this gives the
phantasm series oh yeah you know you
know easily yeah it's kind of a
different thing you got to see the
phantasm series again - that was good
yeah we've done the first one in the
second one on the show right we were I
was gonna do three four and five because
I think shudder has all of I want to see
him again yeah I thought I liked
everything I buy it didn't I buy a set
of it you might have well like I said
shudder has or they did last saw my
shudder yeah we might have but yeah so
this one it's like the gore is way more
over-the-top it's crazier than the first
one cuz like I said you could tell they
were just having a good time trying to
like think of like the nuttiest thing
they could think of a trying to like top
the first one so in that sense if you're
really into gore and you're really into
body horror and [ __ ] like that you
definitely need to see this especially
if you're a fan of like practical
effects and stuff because there's some
really good [ __ ] in this had I seen it
back in the day as a sequel me and my
boys we would not have been a
we would like tit yeah we wouldn't have
n disappointed yeah it's like I said it
gives you more of what you wanted right
it's like you can tell that it's a
slightly different the tone is slightly
different a different director was on
context at the time though yeah it's in
the same wheelhouse though yeah this was
more close to what we were looking for
actually so it got closer to what it was
that we liked yeah yeah so yeah we would
have loved it and like I said I think
it's worth it just I mean even if
[ __ ] Jeffrey Combs wasn't awesome and
everything like that I think it's worth
it just for that [ __ ] part at the end
where the bride falls apart that looks
[ __ ] fantastic and that's like some
of the best like gore effects it's a
great tequila movie that's right Tom
gives this for tequila's out of five but
yeah so anyway like all the reanimate
our movers are good so obviously you
should check them all out this one
shudder just added it a couple weeks ago
which is why we decided to go ahead and
review it since we already did the first
one on the third one so we figured we'd
do the one in the middle so check it out
yeah Brian of reanimate er 1990